I thanked our Johnny continued are you
ready
he is ready ready as ever I wonder
what's in here did you hear that story
about us splitting apart
don't worry anything that's never gonna
happen ever
it's going on now
the doors closed behind us huh is that
what has come to I guess we got a fight
sorry I banked I love you Ben I'm not
gonna kill you don't worry about it
don't even worry about it my bro my bro
whiskey my bro chef my bro-heem my broke
brother my bra my friend my bro sandwich
my brolly
my brand my dama what's going on here
man whoa
okay like that well sorry bank sorry
there's something over here
what is this
carpet
I'll be taking all of you
awesome we're up here can we jump Matt I
don't have enough carpets they keep
running away
ah he gave me powers how does that work
why are we supposed to go huh
uh whoa are we under water it feels like
it doesn't that let me check up here if
I can make it oh I did make it
am i letting up the carpets here all
right I think I got this whoa what is
this place it's magical and mysterious
mysterious let's look like it
yeah we are in the water what Holly I'm
gonna happen I don't even have banked
are you sing lighting something what's
going on
nope don't wanna fall down now he's gone
on banked I thought we're going over
here did you find something banked
I was trying to jump but he fails silly
bangs he doesn't know what's the win I
am a way for him banked here my god I
like my unibrow I want this epic cape
I want it the Little Red Riding Hood
gate I love how my legs are so short
compared to my torso actually they're
not that sure but it looks kind of funny
thanks are you struggling all right
finally good job Aang you did your best
is there something you want to tell me
oh I love how we illuminate when we
touch true love right there schürrle let
me just fly here through that I don't
told me I don't know what to call an
English those things I grow underwater
and I usually put them when I was young
I put them over my eyes and then I made
it into a turtle you know the turtles I
made it into a turtle ninja man those
were the days I messed up space bank I
think we need these to get up
that is my opinion I'm not sure how I'm
doing this but I'm doing it my god you
can fly pretty freakin high alright and
off we go what what is that
but it's that it's madness I don't know
what it's called jellyfish awesome but
fun a secret banked over here banked
down run away from me I don't know what
these do but I got one cool
ie what's that
what's up television huh octopus you're
back
where's banged up I thought he was with
me I'm scared
thanked night
bang-bang always there okay
Bengt
radio you flew over me Annie no it's
still here it's that crazy [ __ ] doin
always up to no good
really oh yes the helmet
Oh banged you so crazy
don't you ever run away from me like
that all right or I run my brother Ramon
all right so we have arrived some way
what it says they don't do anything
what are those structures on the wall
look like snakes or something what do
you think those are banked wolf sir evil
creatures I think we are at the enemy
base bank don't worry I'm with you if
you're scared we can hold hands
it's a shame we don't have any hands
stop fighting bank gallant
I got me banged up tire bury me in the
sand but never mind I'm fine I have to
kill that thing I think what do we do
don't panic bank whatever you do don't
panic [ __ ] we're [ __ ] think we're so
[ __ ]
we're gonna die here we're gonna die in
your bank bank twitch good baked don't
leave me please Bank
son of a [ __ ] got me I'm scared you go
first bang it's one of none of those
things I don't like it oh man
this game is just full of whoa whoa did
you see that bang yes you did
well well I'm scared you go first you go
first
careful now now let's hide here you're
smarter than your like banked I mean
you're looking exactly like me but good
I don't look that smart let's be honest
all right let's hide here no scam
reminds me of this game reminds me of
what is it called what is it called [ __ ]
I don't remember I don't know I don't
know breath I don't know what it's
called
batani gonna I don't know why because
it's like a super force it's pretty
generic it's tornado but I'm not going
in that line Bank how about here and
there's and there's
No
[ __ ] man I don't like it either bang
don't worry pitch don't worry I'm I am
worried thing why is he hiding there you
should have told me I could hide a crazy
person
let's make out picked what are we doing
is it safe
is it safe get it safe all right what
are we going out
jumping through the sand because that's
our boss I am I don't feel all [ __ ]
another one banked alright
ah I gotta make it tell my children I
love them tell our children I love them
right we don't have channel I don't have
to do you have gentlemen do you have no
okay you're single
huh interesting I see how I did the
power source yes over here I got it
don't worry thing
yes
the power of love bros and gentlemen the
power of love between bank and parents I
don't know why Bank is a man hey it's
called a bromance all right geez already
have to keep asking about it it's a
mother hugging romance I don't like this
banked don't want a pair just fine
we're gonna die banked done why I paired
just follow my labor
god damn it God [ __ ] me ha ha ha ha bang
they met my [ __ ]
now go bang bang
ah thank God we made it
ah Bank don't you ever do that again
dare you hear me alright let's listen to
the Eagle [ __ ] man that was intense
oh [ __ ]
alright what's going on
what's up mama eagle what's the story
about this place sing me a song
Shallon want you
oh no they're dead all of them dead
alright so the Sun covers the city and
and then what we're back with the
tombstones so the tombstones are like
the top of the buildings is that it then
I guess it right I think I did
I'm so full of [ __ ] so the stars are in
Zenit and that and that's where Bank
shall rise Bank is the true hero that
this desert deserves where is it where
is your train sorry I don't know why
dunno where a bank I just love sitting
down with you it's so chill
listen to mama Moo can we call her mama
do you think that's her name
it's pretty epic this room man they
really put a lot on the atmosphere and
the environment and I am all for that
[ __ ] this is our bacon is supposed to be
the fries I cooked all perfectly
krispity krunch [ __ ] crispity
[ __ ] crunch
I'm just literally every time we
progress I'm just hoping it's not gonna
end like that that's a that's how a game
should be I got in trials it's gotta
mean I'm just in the beginning right I
hope so I sure hope so
all right let's continue
I bang what do you think about this
I don't know about this one this place
looks weird
nice color with that it's been awhile
since I seen you do one of them is this
a Chinese restaurant Oh
banged another date you're too cute oh
it's not addressed god damn it I love
Chinese oh there's something here so the
what happened
okay so we are well that makes me find
[ __ ] well so we don't lock this tower by
unlocking the Chinese restaurants that
tells us a story I want to read the
story though for the Bengt will rise
upon the desert land and the tombstones
well I'm literally flying still like
that it's awesome thanks Oh am I suppose
to go up there sobbing I wasn't quite
following whoa whoa we totally changed
it's up here everything is like
different and such all right and some
animal about air I begged you miss all
right never mind fine
oh you get full Kate butter those can't
believe it took me this long to realize
it upgrades your cape is that it I think
so
it looks longer like Maddie no it's not
ruin this game with beta sticks
it's one game one week I know it hurts
for us I know it's a big deal for you
Oh can I fly I found another Chinese
recipe you find it too
alright let's just fly to it oh okay I
see how it works now with a cape
much better alright I'll sing today's
sing to the left sing to the right sing
to them alright what is this saying
alright so that banged end appears
oh the sand rice is that it or is it
just part of it I want to see what this
says so the bank turn appears girls in
the cloud with octopus to the city all
right well I guess it keeps lying then
all right why don't we have buddies bang
all right I guess we got to take one of
these no do you know where to go bang
sighs sure no no right is he flying
where did he go thank you crazy
oh we're going up I see
and see if I can grab these jellyfishes
jellyfish you jelly jelly jelly fish we
can just be chillin here
stop game stopping so gorgeous
the last Chinese restaurant that sounds
like a really good movie
I need this I need this to fly make me
fly Erica all right I think I'll sink to
the left i sink to the right are you
enjoying this brothers as much as I am I
really hope so
it's so fantastic so far I just [ __ ]
love it oh man
Bank doesn't like the stories though but
I have a unibrow so let me read this
bank jumped over a fork and then we met
flying knives you think that's it banked
and yes he agrees all right we must go
up again whoa what is that it's like a
dragon my God my God
this game has dragons I am done I'm done
it's nothing else for me to do here no
way this can't even get more it's an
eagle though it's like a phoenix I think
more like a phoenix
well I'm riding at it and it's beautiful
all right this is going on
all right we should jump off here on us
there
oh we didn't let this oh we never let
this I thought we were lower that's why
Wow
sorry okay that explains a lot
to Bank the boots walk the carpet stairs
I think about that thing let me give you
powers and then then that's they flow
again I thought we could swim in this
how we can
all right so here's the conference
bridge and it done locks itself oh my
god I love this Jess I don't even care
where dad is all right good
I love this Bank I want to take this
moment to say I love you I love you back
our next bridge I'm scared that I will
fall out of it
I never actually fallen except when that
died my phone off the dragon so here's
the last one
is that it
you think those I want you to
participate all right
story will unfold itself and they went
down the pyramid stairs and they sang
some blues together man I'm out I'm out
yeah oh we're going up to the surface
cool cuz we went down so much before
when we were sliding and stuff I guess
there's me hello hello bras hi Isaac a
lad how about you two
all right what's it worth the story
where did this story go wow we can
finally leave this place fly on the
wings with banged fly ha ha all right
banked I hope you enjoyed this so far I
think there's hopefully at least an hour
left of this but I'm gonna have to end
this episode here like and favorite if
you enjoyed I love this so much
subscribe come for a day and I will see
you next episode
oh by the neck that'd be best hey
awesome
going down here no we go in here oh [ __ ]
G for the front door